hey everyone it's Henry here and these
are my favorite snacks
[Music]
so this is my first pick
gushers
a little reasoning behind my picks uh I
purposely picked snacks that reminded me
of certain things when I'm looking at
this it just reminds me of my childhood
I just remember when I was growing up
these were like the snack that I wanted
to eat my mom actually wouldn't let me
eat it because it was just too sweet and
I would always like go to school and
then with my friends when they had their
gushers I'd be like please give me lunch
one and I remember in the package can I
open them oh
I just remember in the package there
were only like three or four it felt
like there were only like two
um
wow I haven't you know gushing like 10
years oh that's good
um
oh yeah
I need that sugar
hold up let me try it
do that again we'll get it right
these are Korean onion rings
in Korean they call them young putting
young means onion ding is
getting his ring yeah that's just the
way Korean way is saying it
a little background on me I was born and
raised in Toronto Canada and then uh
right right at the last year of high
school I got scouted to join the K-pop
scene and then I moved to Korea at that
time it was it was everything was just
just amazing to me everything was wild
it was everything was new to me I
remember
just getting introduced to all these
different foods I mean Korea they have
these really really like creative snacks
but I love these something about it when
you bite into it it's just it just hits
all the spots
it's like deep fried fries no all fries
are deep fried like fries are deep fried
but deep fried again I don't know I just
love these chips it's been my favorite
for a very very long time
was that a fail all right this is my
next one I feel like people these days
don't really know what these are anymore
these are called Pop Rocks these were
like the cool kids candy I wasn't really
cool back then you know not really cool
right now but I tried to be cool so I
always tried to have some of these
people that don't know them
they're just not normal candies it's
like a powder powder candy so I still
remember when I first ate this I was
like what what is this is so weird and
once I put it in my mouth it was like
wow I don't know if we can capture this
but I'm gonna try our best
[Applause]
if the sound isn't coming out I'm gonna
look so stupid
playing no Skittles
I actually have this really weird way of
eating Skittles one way of course is you
know we all do it but we all do the
I'm just kidding that wasn't it we all
do the
we all do the
tossing in the air
but what I like doing I don't know if
anyone else does this it's really weird
I've been doing this ever since I was
young I like to smush the Skittles it
feels like you're not gonna be able to
squish it because it's really hard but
it like slowly works it becomes like
this
this smoosh squiddle a squiddle
smush Skittle
it's the same thing but it just it just
tastes better have you ever done that
before no nobody never really
you're lying like not even by mistake
like you put it in your pocket or
something and you sat down that's how I
discovered it um
we'll work on our teamwork yeah for the
next one yeah
I am an Oreo lover I love everything
with Oreos anything to do with Oreos a
lot of people probably know this but
Oreos with milk is just amazing and the
secret is you have to time it perfectly
you can't just like dip it in and put it
like you won't taste it so you gotta
like make sure it's like in there for a
bit just about now you can't leave it in
for too long because what happens is the
Oreo starts to get soggy and then it
just loses its taste so about a good
what was that like 10 15 seconds
that's good you'll notice that your milk
will have a lot of crumbles inside it
and that's the best part
this one you guys do right okay okay
we're together on this one
um how are we gonna do this is it Tim
how are we gonna do this
it's the last one
high toss
oh what if we don't get it this time
should we just try something safer so
that it makes us look both look good
[Music]
last but not least
Fruit Roll-Ups they've accompanied me
through my entire life my entire career
wow I haven't seen this in so long oh I
feel like I'm gonna
[Music]
I still remember when
We Were Young they had these I don't
know if they have them anymore they have
these designs oh they have the designs
and then we would all open them up
together
and then see what everyone else got
they're also tongue tattoos
um I know it sounds weird I'm not gonna
do it here but actually
turn around for that
mm-hmm
huh look at that
really it looks good yeah
after you just eat it it also tastes
really good
you could like scrunch it all up like
eat in one go like this
um
give me a moment I'll show them
hmm
[Music]
yeah I had a great time with snack
literally brought me back to to my
childhood thank you so much for that I
actually just finished working on my new
album I really put in my whole life
story into this album please check that
out and thank you so much for this
amazing amazing experience
[Music]